after 9/11 Airbus introduced this new
reinforced cockpit door part of that is
a system that controls three locks
there's a code pad outside the cockpit
for crew members press a button that
notifies the pilot that you want to be
allowed in and then he uses a switch in
the cockpit to unlock the door Lufthansa
says the captain of the Germanwings
flight tried to do this of the cockpit
attempts to get back in that's one way
the system is used now a couple other
things the system can do in these are of
the most interest to investigators if a
crew member tries to enter the cockpit
then there's no response from inside
there's a four-digit code the crew
member can enter that activates a loud
buzzer and flashing light inside the
cockpit pilot doesn't do anything the
cockpit door will open automatically 30
seconds later but a pilot also has the
ability to override the code manually
and keep a door locked for up to five
minutes but thinking here is that if
there's someone who's trying to get into
that cockpit who shouldn't the pilot can
keep the intruder out